it is the result of the sanction
imposed
on afghanistan
so
it
returns to those who have imposed the
sanctions
which have resulted
in
a humanitarian crisis in afghanistan
on our behalf
during the last
six months
we have done
what we have
we had in
our
capacity
to do
for the people of afghanistan
and we
will continue to do so in order to
alleviate
the
suffering the problems of the people of
afghanistan but it needs
the international community
to cooperate with us
not to punish the people of afghanistan
by imposing
unjustified
sanctions in the country
but to have those sanctions relieved to
gain that recognition you say you want
the international community uh requires
you to do some pretty simple things that
you've said you will do but you haven't
done yet
guarantee the rights of women of
minorities open up education to all
so many simple things why haven't they
happened yet
those things has
happened
because it is the demand of the people
of afghanistan
we have no problem
with women
having access to work and
through education a few days ago
our minister of higher education
announced
opening of all universities
to both
male and female students
so that
issue is resolved
only
in some places
there may be
the issue of capacity like not having
enough number
of
lecturers and professors and like
not
having
money
to
carry out our programs it is
the obligation of the international
community
to provide us
cooperate as financially
in order to achieve that
goal